hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and
Starman waiting in the sky so raise your
hand if when you were a kid you really
wanted to be an astronaut you keep your
hands up if there's a part of you that
still kind of does we're here at the
Johnson Space Center in Houston Texas to
find out if I have the right stuff so
far ladies and gentlemen meet dr. Kjell
Lindgren she'll just got back from 141
days on the ISS so here we have all the
exercise equipment that we use on the
International Space Station so first
we're gonna start with the treadmill now
of course if you were in space and
you're floating above this it's not
going to do you a whole lot of good so
what we do is we strap in to pull you
down onto the treadmill about how much
extra on my body do I have right now
four miles bro
that's work that pass yeah I'll give you
a faster so this is the advanced
resistive exercise device with this
device we're pulling against a vacuum in
order to generate resistance that's a
good starting place yeah that's that
that's heavy
nice work fast this is the cycle
ergometer this is essentially an
exercise bike the one major difference
is the space there's actually their seat
when you're at home with the wife and
stuff you want to relax are you like hey
baby you want to Netflix and chill ha ha
ha no I don't use I don't use my name as
a verb that's probably good he passed
that test let's let's run through it
what what do I need to be an aspirin I
need a four-year degree in a math
science or engineering discipline I do
have an MFA in acting that doesn't meet
the basic cut what are the next things
you guys are looking when we pull in our
Docs from the flight medicine clinic and
they do a pretty thorough physical
candidates are here for roughly a week
that's a serious a lot of turning to the
left and a lot of coughing yes I assume
there would be some form of drug testing
the astronaut position is a drug testing
position yes ok
will they be screening for like injuries
or anything like that like say joint
injuries
that's probably included in the physical
we'll see how I do on that so here's my
spacesuit test tell me what we're
looking at so right here we have a glove
box fitted with two EMU spacesuit gloves
and what we're gonna do here is
depressurize the glove box that the
pressure is the same pressure that you
would see in outer space
and it should be considerably more
resistance right yeah I really feel this
is the overall force required to move
your finger joints the fingers are so
rigidly from failing the getting my food
in the gloves test there we go okay
that's a good start but I think you save
it okay so the first thing we can have
you is mess with the other tether hooks
so this is your lifelines if you can't
use it you can't even move around right
it's like a docking point on the ship
okay open click in close safe those
paths wait up first ride though yeah
this is the space vehicle mock-up
facility it's all of a sudden you hear
the Capcom call up and say hey you need
to respond to a toxic atmosphere
emergency so I come up here a worn
NESTA's rear and hit the ATM at the
atmosphere and then I'm going to rush
down to the Russian segment okay gather
but you're dead ammonia has been coming
in this full time and and you're not
breathing anymore damn okay different
for the so let's rewind now you see the
atmosphere or I'm gonna come over here
and the portable breathing apparatus
bust out this mask flip the switch throw
it on my face and I'm breathing okay so
we can move through here the initial
response is really good okay except for
the first time that way except for
failing and dying yeah well we'll call
that a see what is this beautiful beast
this is the space exploration vehicle or
the SCV with a prototype for the moon or
an asteroid mission we'd be down to give
me a dry address let's go you are
driving if your stick push it sideways
it's a simulated lunar kick over here
and over there we've got a simulated
Mars scape biggest feature of our lunar
yard is the craters craters and remember
we've got active suspension so it's
cured in all the wheels on the ground
all the time the wheels go 360 degrees
around and actually have an infinite
number of turns donuts so we tried to
make the rover so that you didn't need a
lot of skills and drive it clearly got
the hydraulics just something like
really slow lowrider style and if I hit
the switch I can make the ass drop so I
passed the driving test yeah that's the
driving side of it can I go for extra
credit
you can can i ghost ride the whip go
what
welcome to the spicy food systems
laboratory what do you got for me today
I'll start with a beverage okay just so
you know it's time it's time it's time
it's tanks so we'll start off with our
beef stew all right here we go it's just
like a denting or can beef stew we have
broccoli I'll gotten buzz good this one
is the triple-t snack bread also nice
got a little kick to it mm-hmm we will
finish off with our chocolate pudding
cake oh it's really good I could totally
do that pretty here pass pass pass so
what did we learn here today obviously
there's a ton involved in being an
astronaut we were really only able to
scratch the surface in our one day here
at the Johnson Space Center with the
right education and training a lot of
this seems really attainable
moreover we learned that I absolutely
positively without question could
definitely be an astronaut I just need
to go back to college for four or five
or six years what do you think do you
have what it takes let us know in the
comments below subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already and with all that being
said there's only one thing left to do
so Brent when I was heading outside of
the building the guys at the control
desk taught me and just one to let me
know they have you on tape dancing you
know with those dance moves it's gonna
be if it comes down sorry about that man
I'll try it at the very end I mean come
on
look at all these monitors here how
could you not know that we were watching